why is jeremy wade afraid to pee in the
river hint there's one creature that
creeps him out more than any other keep
watching to find out the untold truth of
river monsters
what started out as a childhood hobby
turned into a lifelong passion for river
monster's host jeremy waite speaking
with wanderlust he revealed that he
learned how to fish from a friend and
subsequently started angling in the
local waterways of his rural english
hometown when the hobby became too
popular locally wade took a three-month
trip to india the first of his many
international fishing excursions after
the trip wade long to explore other
remote areas for fish which led to a
period of simple living and working odd
jobs until he saved just enough for his
next journey wade even nearly died from
malaria during one trip on the congo
river yet he returned to the same area
multiple times eventually his personal
passion for traveling and catching
strange fish led to the opportunity to
do it for a living while i was doing
that i just became aware that there must
be some tv potential here after a
producer saw a newspaper photo of wade
holding a huge fish from the amazon he
got his first shot a 2002 documentary
called jungle hooks a few years later
wade got the green light for a limited
series that eventually caught the eye of
animal planet the rest is history
jeremy wade often talks about one of his
favorite catches being the goliath
tigerfish which is a kind of giant
piranha only found in the congo river
that can weigh over a hundred pounds in
an interview with the telegraph he
revealed that he traveled to the region
three times over a six-year period
before river monsters before he caught
one but it wasn't as big as he'd hoped
and it certainly wasn't enough for the
guy who'd eventually build his career on
hooking the biggest rarest fish in the
world the show returned to the congo
river in its second season when he ended
up hooking a 78-pounder which wade said
was the prize he'd been after for nearly
25 years but for a man like wade the
thrill of the hunt is never over he told
outside online i find that i catch a
fish and my thought is great i've done
that but immediately i know there are
bigger ones out there
when river monsters started it would
have been hard to imagine the phenomenon
it quickly became jeremy wade surely had
a good number of ideas for episodes
based on his own research and study but
with the series eventually going nine
seasons a lot more creatures got added
to the list later on the show even
dipped into more sensational waters with
its chernobyl and loch ness monster
episodes instead of writing things out
until low ratings or a lack of ideas
forced to show off the air wade and his
team decided to hang it up once they
felt they'd wrangled every river monster
out there in a press release announcing
the end of the series he wrote some
shows can run forever but our subject
matter is finite ten years ago i had a
list in my head which seemed impossibly
ambitious at the time but everything has
now been ticked off and then some
over the course of his adventurous life
jeremy wade has contracted malaria had a
gun pulled on him and been interrogated
by authorities on suspicion of spying
and that's all before river monsters
even began since then he's been bitten
jabbed and rammed in the chest by an
80-pound arab hyman in the amazon so
hard that his heart was bruised i i was
honestly i was still feeling that after
six weeks it was such a solid blow crew
members on the show were even struck by
lightning in one episode but when asked
by wanderlust to pinpoint the biggest
danger of his adventures wade had a
surprising answer that had nothing to do
with the water he said the thing that i
worry most about is road traffic indian
mountain roads for instance no tread on
the tire a driver whose belief is that
it is karma that will decide his fate
not the state of his vehicle granted
from the man who voluntarily attached a
blood-sucking lamprey to his own neck it
kind of makes sense that wade's personal
boogeyman aren't aquatic
during a reddit ama jeremy wade revealed
that he's most creeped out by the
kandaru this is the fish that legends
say swims up the urethra and can only be
removed by surgery spreads its thorny
little spines
refuses to butch
have to cut it out
that's it man that's right it's a small
parasitic catfish that latches onto the
gills of host fish by spreading out
little spines then feeds on their blood
wade reiterated his revulsion for the
little amazon parasite on an episode of
river monster saying it's one of the
most disgusting fish i've had to get to
grips with
it's easy to assume that the demographic
watching fishing shows like river
monsters would be primarily male 1 let's
go fishing
however that's not as accurate as you
might think when it comes to the animal
planet show according to a chicago sun
times report from 2012 the series
audience was 40 female though that
number might sound surprising at first
it shouldn't necessarily be a shock
modern data from statistas shows that
close to 40 percent of fishing
participants in the us are women wade
also did a fabulous job as the host of
river monsters creating a tone that was
widely accessible wade himself has
expressed a humble perspective on the
show's broad appeal telling real screen
we decided early on to go with this as a
bit of a detective story we're also
showcasing different areas of the world
in different people which audiences are
interested in
given that many river monsters filming
locations are incredibly remote the
danger posed by injuries is heightened
beyond your average reality show it's
those random
things out of the environment which are
the ones that that can catch you
unawares in his reddit ama jeremy wade
explained that because episodes were
often filmed far from civilization both
he and the crew were trained for
hazardous situations he said they always
carried emergency medical kits along
with a satellite phone that all makes
sense given the circumstances and the
training has certainly come in handy
time and again but in the same post wade
then tacked on this little tidbit of
info and the production company always
asks two questions on the rare occasions
we call them if there is an emergency
question one is everybody okay question
two immediately afterwards did you film
it over its eight year run river
monsters sought out scores of wild
bizarre creatures but of all wade's
finds the single most surprising was a
marooned sailor on an unpopulated island
and the next thing we knew there was a
guy looking rather sort of wild and
ragged
staggering down the beach towards us
while filming the season 8 episode death
down under in northern territory
australia wade and crew spotted
something unusual even for them a blue
and white cooler sitting on an otherwise
uninhabited island then the team spotted
its owner a sunburned dehydrated
fisherman who upon spotting the team
yelled out desperately for water the man
was later identified as a local
fisherman he told the crew that he had
lost track of his boat while hunting for
oysters on the small island as wade
notes in the episode the area's average
daily temperature hovers around 100
degrees fahrenheit and the extreme heat
had taken a toll the river monster's
crew were able to rehydrate him rescue
him and bring him back to civilization
for medical treatment
water levels greatly affected jeremy
wade's ability to find and catch
monsters of the deep in fact in a chat
with the big lead wade explained that
there are certain times of the year when
fish are so spread out due to high flood
waters that quote they can be impossible
to find some of that predictably has to
do with climate change which wade once
said made the annual river cycle
unpredictable in more recent times of
course rising global temperatures have
other detrimental effects on aquatic
wildlife as well
you probably wouldn't be surprised to
learn that the river monsters production
team didn't have it easy an average
episode consists almost entirely of wade
spending countless hours angling and
baiting all while cameramen work in the
same conditions to capture every
precious shot we get maybe one chance
with one massive fish that after maybe a
week of trying jeremy pulls in many
episodes of river monsters took a heavy
toll on the crew's time money sanity and
even safety as wade has explained each
episode of the show took around three
weeks to shoot that length may already
surprise but what's perhaps more
surprising is that out of those three
weeks according to wade only about three
or four days normally are spent fishing
that leaves around 18 days during which
the crew would focus on non-fishing
hurdles and there were hurdles of plenty
for example director kelly neves has
detailed a few such issues that the crew
faced while searching for humboldt squid
in peru the challenges included a boat
too small for the crew a language
barrier between crew and guides ocean
sickness lack of safety precautions and
even the threat of pirates and that's
just one episode
despite the numerous monsters that have
taken a bite out of jeremy wade he's not
a vengeful man wade has always conducted
himself as a biologist and researcher
first and an angler only as a secondary
necessity to that end wade doesn't keep
trophies from his catches even the
incredible ones and he avoids eating
fish for the most part during his ama on
reddit wade revealed his
sustainability-based policy when it
comes to pisciviry saying that he only
eats fish if there's no threat to their
population he explained the choice
further to page six saying it's sort of
out of conscience i like to eat
sustainably produce fish where possible
for the same reason wade isn't
interested in keeping fish's trophies
his angling expeditions are meant to
educate and assess local legal systems
which is why almost every river
monster's catch can be seen on camera
swimming away after its brief running
with weight to supplement his on-site
adventures with at-home education wade
also frequently lectures about
conservation at universities and
scientific conferences speaking with the
guardian wade expanded on his education
and conservation efforts saying there
has been a marked decline in fish sizes
over the last few years i've witnessed
that myself and by talking to people
these are large animals some of them
larger than people and they're
disappearing before our eyes he said
that his preferred catch and release
approaches quote the only way that
freshwater fish stand a chance worldwide
given that wade is such a dedicated
biologist it makes sense that he cares
so deeply about all other elements of
the planet's health as well check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite show's untold truths are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one